i'm here with my wife and we thought you
know what we're going to be talking
about
the prophet salallahu's character what
the prophet taught us i'm going to have
a hashtag
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum welcome to that cartoon
brothers and sisters and dear friends
now as you guys may know that um that
before i start one place also finals are
the most most of the most trust or
praises of glory and gratitude belong to
him
to rectify intentions and accept our
deeds from us
as you guys have gone sisters in france
in in many places and
for god knows how long the prophet
salallahu has been slandered
his character has been mocked and this
has been going on fourteen hundred years
ago from abu jahl tabulah
may allah's curse be upon them um and
the prophets have always faced this
at salaam sharing the affliction of
mercy we are starting a new series where
we're going to be delving into the
prophet
sallallahu alaihis character in person
we're going to demonstrate that you may
be
little sketches or be it me and my wife
um doing certain things in charlotte our
aim with this video is not
to um show you that we're all happy
lucky family whoo
to shoot no no please we're not here to
do that just to make something clear
because we want people to
be like oh my look you don't know
nothing about our private life uh
exception
is bad or good but i'm not here to
represent something
um and you know marriages are upside
down but it's not about that video so
i'm not here to show us couples etc so
just to give that disclaimer
i'll get you into the video i'm here
with my wife and
we thought you know what we're going to
be talking about the prophets character
what the prophet told us i'm going to
have a hashtag inshallah
i think that's the hashtag what the
prophet told us or something that i was
like it's about the hairstyles there
so i had an idea with my wife so sarah
okay so here's the idea i want you to
tell me what you think okay
i thought block dawn's coming next
thursday is going to be a lockdown yeah
so i thought what what if i'm going to
do it staying at home
sleeping watching movies whatever it may
be okay
they're not going to do much so i
thought you know what let's
put into action something the prophet
saw
yeah which was what that the prophet
salallahu said to us that angel gabriel
came to him so much so that and he
emphasized on the right of
the neighbors that the prophet said that
he feared that he said you know what
there might be
like i fear andrew is going to come and
say you know what your neighbors could
inherit from you
so this is the right of the neighbors
and some of the self said your neighbors
are
from sleeping 40 to your right 42 your
left 40 in front of you and 40 behind
you okay
so obviously that's a lot of neighbors
take care of but
i have the problem an idea why don't we
write a letter to our neighbors
from us and we'll go and deliver it to
them yeah so those who open the door
will speak to them and tell them what
it's about and in our obviously the flat
that we live in
there are some females known as some
females who live alone
you know and so we thought you know
something that you can do yourself
because
you know females you know um so let's
start writing the letter
yeah okay so are you ready yeah because
i need your help with english because my
english is bad
let's start off with um
dear neighbor how's that
yeah that's fine yeah
okay
that's good to give salaam
not to reply yeah so let's start with
dear
to our dear neighbors yeah that's at the
top
that's it okay guys so we've drafted
that what we're going to do now is we're
going to go
with my wife uh get that printed and
maybe find some
cards
um
is so basically
the only ones we could find with the
neighbor it's this one
bobby says this greeting comes to wish
you
a wish you lots of christmas trees so
we're gonna have to get
by sticker to cover that because about
that christmas life
so guys where am i today so i'm going to
get this
the letter that we wrote before instead
of putting it separately
we'll print it off small and put it on
top of the bit where
it says about season greetings because
we're not really
giving this card because of that and
we'll just put it over there so it
killed two birds with one stone so i'm
gonna go get that printed and i thought
on the left side
i can put a picture of a hadith
well before i print it off can you show
me what it looks like
before i print i want to send for print
this one um which
yes it looks a bit christmassy but it
doesn't we've covered so
inside as you can see i've tried to make
a bit creative
you can see here
but the main ones that we've got are
these ones so for example
as you can see it says to our
for a special neighbor this bit here i
found a little bit of a creative way to
cover that
so what i'm gonna do
[Music]
[Music]
why but that's what i'm going to be
doing in charlotte
here
just put it here
all right from us
yeah you know there's a lock down it's
just a little message from us to you
guys because you know
if you have anything that you need um
just let us know
if it's like shopping you might not need
you might have a car oh yeah but if you
need anything put the lock down yeah
okay just let us know just for us okay
thanks
do you know the card yeah thank you
yeah a little snake
[Music]
hello
okay and if you need anything uh let us
know just a message from us to you guys
if you need anything if you don't have a
car or if you if you need sugar
however
um if you need any help because you know
it's gonna be locked down oh hold on
come on let me call you back
i'm sorry okay yeah um
cause a lot of that's happening in
florida if you need any help if you
don't have a car shopping
okay um obviously my wife will like if
you need if we're going to
do shopping yeah if you need anything
just tell us
yeah yeah the way you know just in case
yeah just check up on the clothes
because we live
in a remote area because we're muslims
and taking care of their needs is very
important
oh that's lovely thank you for watching